[Music]
[Music]
yuccas a games do two things very well
grab you with dramatic stories and
over-the-top characters and make you
laugh with oddball side-missions that
knowingly lean into their absurdity the
latest game yakuza kiwami is no
exception it's gripping and funny
juvenile at times and self-reflexive at
others it's a difficult game to
categorize but it's infectious free
spirit is immediately uplifting and
identifiable some people got their first
taste of Yakuza when it debuted in 2005
and for them kiwami is a remake of the
game that started it all it is for the
most part a straightforward recreation
of the first Yakuza game there have been
minor adjustments made to account for
the current state of the series extended
narrative and contemporary combat
systems but it's largely a faithful
adaptation where it counts for other
people
kiwami is the follow-up to Yakuza 0 the
prequel that arrived earlier this year
barring the Japanese exclusive samurai
themed spin-off Yakuza yishun Yakuza 0
was the first in the series current
timeline and the first Yakuza game on
PlayStation 4 making it the perfect
starting point for newcomers kiwami is a
natural sequel for recent Yakuza
inductees
despite its 2005 DNA you travel the same
streets of seedy kominato
a plane on Tokyo's red-light district
kabukicho chivalrous Yakuza soldier
Kazuma Kiryu remains in the spotlight
and though the world around him has gone
through some slight changes he's still
the same old sued gangster with a
furrowed brow a heart of gold and fists
of fury the games thirteen chapters
follow a familiar pattern presenting a
self-contained mini conflict that plays
into the bigger picture with
opportunities to explore the city
between cutscenes kiwami generously
provides waypoints for your next major
objective so you always feel comfortable
setting main missions aside as they're
easily picked back up again but when you
do Camacho's footprint is rather modest
compared to contemporary open worlds
meaning you're repeatedly sent to the
same few locations over and over again
at some point you grow weary of running
to one corner of the map knowing full
well that whomever awaits is just going
to direct you elsewhere after the
briefest of conversations it doesn't
help that you're frequently interrupted
with combat encounters along the way
fights on the streets of camacho play
out in an outdated beat-em-up format
where stiff controls and storms of
enemies lead to frequent battles of
attrition and despite
offering an impressive amount of
character progression which includes
earning extremely violent takedowns as
well as strategic maneuvers for your
various fighting styles kiwami x'
battles remain consistently
underwhelming after the initial joys of
brutalizing street tuff's
wears off
[Music]
though you don't get to control zero
standout character
goro majima he is still a prominent part
of the overall experience
goro delights himself in picking fights
with you to satisfy his own masochism
and to help you regain atrophied skills
after his stint in prison that occurs
early on in kiwami along with
wonderfully weird side quests that pop
up as you explore kamurocho these
surprise events give exploration a sense
of purpose he wanna meas primary story
is heavy defined by murder and betrayal
and while it can be wholly captivating
the game's lighter pursuits provide
necessary catharsis from your life of
crime beyond its light-hearted
sub-stories kiwami also offers a host of
minigames that can take hours to master
many of these such as darts and mahjong
are straightforward and traditional
experiences and closely mirrors eros
renditions others such as bikini clad
women cosplaying as bugs fighting game
are well essentially therefore
titillation opting to be sexy rather
than challenging in this regard kiwami
offers plenty of adult pursuits that
aren't shy about leaning into the game's
pervasive machismo this same lack of
restraint can also be credited with
Yakuza as more prominent qualities cut
scenes are often hyper-emotional
exchanges backed by impassioned Japanese
voice acting that despite the language
barrier strike a chord likewise curious
finishing moves in combat display a fair
amount of creative delight in the
unusual ways that cure you is able to
take advantage of the environment and
nearby props turned weapons these don't
always turn a boring fight into an
exciting one but creative violence along
with far-out humor and sexy distractions
is part of the reason Yakuza games are
uniquely exhilarating despite the
presence of obvious flaws
hawawa does a great job both as a remake
of the original Yakuza game and as a
sequel to zero
despite that combat remains more of a
bump in the road than a rewarding
pursuit the game is still a no brainer
for existing fans in the series and
shouldn't be overlooked by newcomers
even if zero passed them by there was
nothing else quite like Yakuza and
kiwami
isn't afraid to show it
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]